hey everybody and welcome to a truly
wild ride with stevo
this week we have a legend of the
wu-tang clan
a guy i've known for a long long time
who's always been
super cool to me and man i was looking
forward to this
so much it was everything that i thought
it would be and more
get ready to be excited again ladies and
gentlemen
method man yeah dude good to see you bro
with you ah dude i've been i've been
doing so well
i want you to meet my co-host scott
randolph right here what's up math
up at the front of the van we've got the
gorgeous paul briskey
hey man how are you nice to meet you and
this right here is my uh
my life partner wendy
yeah dude thank you i found her in the
streets of peru
wow and brought her all the way here so
we got a an immigrant
even better yeah south american stray
dog dude and she's the best
so am i correct i'm sure i am dude i've
i've not seen you since that uh incident
in 2006 at rock the bells
yeah it might have been that yeah just
going right out the gate with it
well i mean what do you want it's a
notable thing that happened i like it
i uh it was um i mean i i've
told that story a couple times recently
i told it to eric
andre on uh on the podcast we had him on
and uh i guess i only told it that once
yeah
eric is the kind of guy that would have
tried to pull something like that too
but eric would have got beat up
we don't we don't know eric like we know
you steve
right i mean dude i i went i mean i
literally like
i don't know i just i felt like kind of
traumatized by that
and and not even traumatized but like
traumatized by feeling guilty you know
like i i've never for all my uh
crazy antics for all for all the the
stuff i i do
i've never been the guy who tried to
offend people or upset people you know
like
i've always done my my [ __ ] like at my
own expense you know like i'm the butt
of the joke and i'm like
you know like i don't do like mean or
offensive [ __ ] so uh
yeah that didn't sit well with me and i
remember um bumping into rizza
at some point after that i saw him
somewhere and i was like hey man dude
like
you know uh yeah i want to acknowledge
that did i want to try and make it right
and rizzo was like dude i
i didn't care you know like ah yeah
because rizza rizza knows your heart he
knew that it wasn't done in an offensive
manner
but at that moment in time in that space
with
you know dirty's mother being there and
things nature because even i
didn't really think because you told me
he was going to do it and i was like
steve if you're going to do that
okay i mean no
but um in the space that it happened in
i i i wasn't offended by it until
chef brought it to my eyes that the
people who were present may be offended
by it
right see i'm in show mode so when that
was brought to my attention it hit me
like oh
right wow and i'm pretty sure it hit you
like that too probably like oh
yeah what i didn't think of that part of
it you know what i mean
and that's how i basically took it and i
think a lot of the other members
probably took it that way too but some
was genuinely
freaking pissed right yeah for sure man
and uh
boy rayquan turned me into a real [ __ ]
real fast um i've seen them do that
before the other people so
yeah hey give me what it is bro
real quick for anyone who didn't see the
eric andre episode like what what are
you guys talking about what happened
that's that's a fair question so it was
uh 2006 it was a big rock the bells
uh festival there were uh it was
headlined by wu-tang uh they had all
kinds of
great acts but but wu-tang was last i
was there all day just getting sloppy
drunk
i'm hanging out with method man like in
the back and
i'm telling method man yo when i was
locked up in
uh in la correctional facility in the
twin towers
they took me out of my cell and i was
hanging out with the cops in there and
they said yo
dude you're in odb cell he's always in
here
and uh and i was like man that just made
me feel like i love odb
and you know we were we were like cell
mates man i want to do something like
i want to do something on stage at the
show to uh you know
to like as a tribute to odb you know i
think he'd love it i'm going to get
butt naked i'm going to flip my balls
back and forth and
cannot tell it like he told me
i'm gonna flip my balls and dig back and
forth and catch in a mangina
and while i'm standing there with my
mangina then i'm gonna do a perfect back
flip
and i'm gonna and dude dude it actually
ended up being the the best
double backpack flip i ever laid i never
landed one that clean in my life
but yeah so it started and at first it
was all like kind of fun and games we
were joking around backstage like oh man
that's funny
and then meant the man came up to me a
little while later before
before they went on he says you can't do
it dude he says they're gonna kick your
ass
and i said let him kick my ass man odp
would probably love that
and uh okay this is probably during the
pcp days right
right and then when you know it's like
so many things dude it's like oh yeah
let that and then
when it actually happens i'm like i'm
sorry i'm sorry
and this was on stage oh yeah dear
rayquaza so i did
it like like method man said odb's mom
was there
like it was this like tribute to him and
you know i i grabbed the mic i'd do my
thing and like uh
dude and it was actually kind of nobody
seemed that upset at first
and then they played like shimmy yeah
and and brooklyn zoo and it was like
we're all having a good time but then
all of a sudden like
rayquan just grabs me by the neck with
both hands and he's like
yo you're gonna apologize man that was
disrespectful
i'm gonna level with you this story is
really
intense and hearing it from both me and
method man
might take a lot out of you you might
need to lay down
and let me recommend laying down on a
mattress from helixsleep.com
why well not just because of the
statistics i just learned about
dust mites and bed bugs but because
helixsleep.com
tells you what is the perfect mattress
for you
by giving you a simple two-minute quiz
and by putting in that information it
tells you the best mattress for you
and i love my mattress from helix
sleep.com
so much i just cannot recommend it
enough
plus i'm going to give you a great deal
right now if you go to helixsleep.com
stevo
you get up to 200 off of any mattress
and remember it's gonna be a perfect
mattress for you
plus they throw in two free pillows
and i love my helix pillows so much too
oh for god's sakes
it is time for you to step up your
sleeping game
so go to helixsleep.como
and enjoy up to 200 off of
any mattress plus two free pillows
now let's hear it on the mic
oh yeah oh yeah he said i wouldn't stop
the music
you stop the music
it was it was a um like you know an
assembly moment when the principal walks
into the room and
because all the students are being too
right and he steps up on stage and says
something like
we don't do that here at mckenna high
school
no wait steve sit your ass down before i
call your mom
you know we know her she's been here a
few times
but damn the lapd for that man talking
about this is dirty cell what kind of
[ __ ] harassment [ __ ] is that
yeah i don't know man they listed off uh
oh they said um who else was cells was
that
we call this robert downey jr blog
because i was in protective custody
see that that's so [ __ ] tacky right
there you know i mean
like go ahead it's all good dude i'm not
i'm not
i'm not like uh i'm not disagreeing with
you they said
it's like a robert downey junior blog
this is where all the celebrities come
it's protective custody so nobody gets
like you know
our high profile inmates they're like we
had tommy lee robert downing jr you know
like odb is always in here they said
you're in as hell
yeah i and i didn't even you know
honestly i just thought
i felt honored to be an odb cell
[Music]
in the mental game it is that you know
they
like they're proud that they had these
and this is some of these celebrities
lowest freaking moments
oh yeah yeah who've been rehabilitated
by the way a lot of them
yeah by the way so for them to still
have those
that that is just terrible man yeah
they're probably in their jail cell like
can i get a selfie with you dude
oh dude like the uh the cops were i just
got my back tattoo
but the movie wasn't out yet so nobody
knew about it and the cops were all
taking pictures with my bag
in their office they took me out of my
cell like into their office
that was cool as hell right i did i was
like man would have been cooler
if they would have let your ass go
[Laughter]
for sure not for nothing
i'm not putting anybody on blast but
when i was in miami one time
and i'm keeping it a buck this is a
honey i was going to my little apartment
i was staying in and you know how those
alleyways go into the garage so i'm in
the alleyway as soon as i turned in
there
they was on me playing car two
uniformed officers white officer gets
out
no lie tells me get out the car i don't
know why he's telling me get out the car
i hadn't asked me a question or anything
i get out the car he starts to ask me
questions and as he's searching me
i got a in my pocket you know tree
whatever
he touches it the other cop gets out and
says method man
black cop and i'm a hundred i'm keeping
it a hundred
says method man looks at his partner and
says nah nah nah leave him alone let him
go
i [ __ ] you not in miami yeah
i ain't even from miami but that day
that's cool [ __ ] right there instead of
a damn cell block after robert downey jr
who's a pillar
of his community that's right yeah yeah
that's a good point
i i had an arrest warrant out on me for
seven years because uh like i got
deserved to go to jail then well right
no doubt about that it was like a
traffic stop and i had expired tags and
so
i couldn't renew my license and all this
[ __ ] so yeah i had no insurance and
so the cop said the cop was like uh
you know this is a criminal deal you
know and so i'm giving you this uh
this this appear in court thing it means
you're actually arrested
but i never went to court so i ended up
with a warrant i had a warrant out for
like seven years one night i was walking
down the sidewalk all
drunk all wasted these cops saw me and
they're like they said uh
yo dude let's get a picture with you
let's say yes steve oh what's
up and i was like oh man and i'm all
drunk i just blurred out
you know i think i have a warrant out
for my arrest and then i'm like why did
i say that like why did i [ __ ] say
that
and the the cops go oh dude what's your
name man what's your real name we'll
look it up and i was like well
if you look it up and i've warned
doesn't that mean you have to take me to
jail
speaking of consequences for being
looked up
let me tell you that when someone looks
up into your nostril and sees
disgusting gnarly nose hair there
are serious consequences for your
reputation with that person
and nose hair is very real you know how
i deal with it
with my weed whacker from
manscapes dude no problemo
takes care of everything absolutely
nick free you want to talk about nick
free i can
shave my balls and like
do it aggressively really make sure i
get in all the places i need to go
and i'm not going to worry about nicking
myself because the lawnmower 3.0
is the best men's grooming device
out there period hands down and i want
you to get a good deal on it so
you're going to go to manscaped.com
stevo and that's going to get you 20 off
your order
plus free shipping yeah dude and
it's not just lawn mowers and weed
whackers
i mean you got ball toner ball deodorant
you got a lot of things that are going
to make you smell better look better and
feel better so one more time for 20
off your order and free shipping go to
manscaped.com
stevo now let's see what the cops said
and they say [ __ ] no what's your name
and
i told him my real name stephen glover
they look it up and they said
yeah you're hot for 10 g's and [ __ ]
they're like have a good one man right
on
i just watched it
was that the same time that they posed
with you holding the bag of weed
um no but i had a warrant out for my
arrest when i was
posing with a bag of weed with like
jesus dude
i mean like how is that fair i don't
know i i
i don't i don't know that it is fair
what was your history with the wu tang
uh before that event um we we had method
man on wild boys with us which was such
a huge honor
yeah there was another time when you
were here for uh
uh it was like the night before like the
i don't know maybe the b-e-t awards
and i think it was that because at the
hotel i went to go hang with matt the
band
oh yeah so you guys were tight i mean i
don't know if it was
how tight we were but he was just always
a bro you know the man was always just
so cool to me
and uh so i met up with method man at
his hotel
and uh yeah i remember you're tripping
too because you're like dude
here in california you can just go to a
store
and buy weed it's like you know now new
york always had a dialed though because
even though it was illegal in new york
they had like the delivery system
you know some guy shows up on a bicycle
and gives you like good ass weed
but it wasn't legal you know here in l.a
then mess like yo just went to a store
and bought this like this is
insane and he's rolling up uh a blunt
i forget with what you had some funny
thing about how you were the master of
rolling blunts
like something
yeah and uh and then so so
so we're smoking this blunt and all of a
sudden i think
i'm like yo dude [ __ ] hey meth
[ __ ]
throw the blunt across your hotel room
i'll catch it in my mouth
sorry so he he met this man's got a big
old hotel room
he throws this lit blood across the room
and i and i gotta catch it right but i
catch it the wrong way
so i got the [ __ ] i catch the burning
end of my lips but i don't care i'm not
gonna drop this thing man this is my
shot
so i i catch it i catch and
it just straight burns my lip and i'm
like yo dude
do i look like i have herpes
you remember that meth yes i do that's
facts he wanted to catch a blunt in his
mouth and [ __ ]
did you tape that steve
dude i have the footage and i've still
never done anything with it
he's got the [ __ ] though he
caught that song [ __ ] he caught it
yeah right yeah it was i forget how we
even filmed it man but uh but yeah dude
17 you've always been so good to me man
i appreciate you so much dude
and congratulations on everything man
like
thank you i'm working man you know who
who would have thought
right right dude me too who peaks at 50.
what the [ __ ] is that
right tell me about it man like i
literally
honestly and i have this one buddy of
mine this one buddy of mine
who's like a sober guy and he would do
our whole you know sober nerd thing
and he's been telling me for years he's
like you know there's been certain times
i'm like kind of down in the dumps i'm
like man dude like
and he says dude steve you haven't even
peaked yet
and i'm like i don't know dude i don't
know and then like
he's been telling me for years and years
you haven't even peaked yet and then at
a certain point like i think about a
year ago i was like damn
that motherfucker's right i haven't even
peaked yet
and that's a real thing right there man
that's why that old adage um if i knew
back then what i know
now you know because the clock is
shorter now
than it was yeah back then and all this
knowledge that we have if we just would
have freaking listened
back then just talking and reacting so
much
you know it would have been way
different way different i'd probably be
a billionaire right now
what were the big lessons that you have
learned
um save your money was the first lesson
save your money
pay taxes money yeah save your money man
and when you find
um and when you find your niche
stick with it and run with it until the
wheels fall off especially if it makes
you happy man
yeah that's cool hey matt i wanted to
ask you because i i was
reading some some interviews that you
were doing you said you know when you're
blowing up you were
there's a part in there where you said
you were eating rice with ketchup on it
because you had no money
so so i love bryce with ketchup
steve eats that now
but so so you start blowing up right
what's the first thing you buy with a
big check
a bigger bag of rice and more ketchup
yeah
that's great ketchup i love that oh man
yeah you know i think too about the
whole like we're
we're getting older and we're doing
great like getting old as a [ __ ]
but damn if you can like if you can get
better as you get older
you know like because with age comes
wisdom with experience
comes skill so you get better at what
you do you know how to
how to like apply your time and and
apply yourself better so like
it really takes the sting out of getting
old when
you're [ __ ] coming up you know still
coming up
yeah i mean and a lot of that has to do
with the fact that
you make a lot of mistakes on the way
there
yeah and i mean if you have a moral
compass and i believe i like to believe
the majority of the people in this world
do you want to do better
you know yeah why when we go to the
movies we love to see a happy ending
because that's what we all want
at the end of the day a happy ending we
just want to win you know
smile at the beginning of the day and go
to sleep with that same smile every
night you know
and when we get to that age where we can
appreciate things more
that smile comes a lot more often
doesn't it yeah
for sure man yeah were you always
inspirational words for me
ten years ago this would have never
happened geez
yeah i did were you always working out
and taking care of your body like you
are now
yeah you have the italian no absolutely
not
um i i was off and on you know and
and that a lot of that had to do with
you know um
me knowing and wanting more for myself
knowing that i could be better than what
i was
and then falling back into i'd do it
tomorrow
yeah ah dude that's right so now you're
the real italian stallion
what huh now you're the real to callie
and stallion
well i was the real to call you stallion
back then but hey always room for
improvement i love that part about it
always room for improvement that's cool
yeah dude so this uh these wu tang shows
they just had two of them and one of
them was like actors playing you guys
where it's scripted
and then the other one was like straight
documentary stuff yeah yeah
like they basically came out at the same
time
and yeah and so that's like i mean
full on wu-tang clan heyday like you
know
philly a lot of that has to do with
rizzo you know he's
he's like one of the smartest people i
know on this planet and i know some
smart people man
and um it was the 25th anniversary what
else could we do
right and i'm glad that everything came
to fruition and
uh yeah man people learned some new
things about us some things that are
actual factual and when you
view the hulu series just take it with a
grain of salt because
it's based right right right right right
yeah right okay i like that
and then now let's talk about what what
you're promoting
like actively you got your movie on
netflix
yeah uh concrete cowboys is coming up
um produced by
rick staub ricky staub he's the director
writer
and um stars idris elba and caleb mc i
hope i say his last name caleb make
stranger days caleb okay
and um i mean i've seen the movie and
this
is a great movie byron bowers uh
lorraine tassant who's
brilliant i love her and um you know i
spent uh
about four or five weeks shooting in
nor in west philadelphia and i had no
idea that there were horses that close
to the hood you know
actually it's like you got your projects
in your
and whatever whatever over here and then
a block away there's horses and stables
and people that
care for these horses and there's a lot
of love and knowledge and things in
history
down there that i had no idea about man
love it love it so if you can catch
concrete cowboys
uh it's going to be on netflix april 2nd
i believe oh nice
and did you shoot that during covid like
no that was way before kobe
thank goodness also shout out to um
the uh there was a girl a young
girl there nyla who um would come out to
set
every day she was one of the local
people
one of the local people's uh daughter
used to bring a smile to my face every
day man
very beautiful soul young lady um
she passed away uh last year
yeah she passed away last year broke my
heart
um but this movie i think
should be dedicated to her because of
all the light and love that she brought
to that set every day but
wow yeah that's cool that's
that's great man do you have a favorite
movie that you've worked on in the past
i mean it's it's
you got belly you have cobbler you have
you have high how high i mean garden
state who here saw
titty i think all of them because
everybody was very patient with me
um and what i mean by that is they
figured i would show up with a big-ass
entourage which i never do
um i was green with the acting chops but
they worked with me anyway
um and trusted my decisions on camera so
i'll say all of them because everybody
got me the way i am right now you know
as dedicated as i am to the craft and um
you know i'm ready to show the world
what i can do now more than that yeah
nice i love it and so so you got power
book two yeah and uh
and when's that that's coming out on
stars
yes we already completed the first
season so if you don't have the stars
app you should go get that
if you can't afford it you should go get
it anyway
you know check out that first season
because the second season is coming up
real fast
and uh we're already uh about three four
episodes in
as far as filming and it's getting
interesting and very hot
yeah and and uh and so you're working
with off with 50 on that
yes sir 50 cent is an executive producer
as well as
courtney kemp and a few other people but
um
i applaud them for even giving me my
shot to uh
step outside my comfort zone so to speak
because i've never done anything
lawyerly or you know i've only had to
use lawyers and never become
that's great man cool i did it sounds
like uh
i i hear a lot of respect for for for
acting for the craft
you've been doing movies forever i mean
you know when you
you i mean even when michael jordan left
basketball
to go play baseball and people there
were a lot of skeptics
if you spoke to mike's teammates they
told you how dedicated he was how he
showed up to practice how
he did everything that was asked of him
to do regardless to how
the skeptics felt and that's
the kind of uh route that i took with
the acting i do i did the work
i got my feet wet i dedicated myself to
it
and now i want to reap the benefits of
being diligent in my practices you know
what i'm saying for sure
one
i like that man i did the same thing
with comedy you know i come out of
jackass and i'm doing stand-up comedy
and people are like man come on dude we
don't want to see stevo doing stand-up
but
i did the work man and i brought my own
like
original like approach to it you know i
didn't try to copy anybody i did it my
way
and it turned into something pretty
special now steve i'm saying like
comedians draw up their real life
experiences that's what was so beautiful
about richard pryor
yeah about growing up in uh in a house
of
leisure so to speak you know your life
has i mean bro come on
you could do a three-day comedy special
bro
you know whatever the [ __ ] you've been
through actual [ __ ] like
i woke up with a [ __ ] bottle rocket
in my ass and it's like
a laugh at this [ __ ] but because it
actually happened
for sure and that's why i took my comedy
is now i do uh
multimedia comedy so i'm doing like
stand up i'm doing an act
but when i'm talking about [ __ ] when i'm
telling jokes when i'm one of my stories
playing out
i i got the footage edited into it
wow that's dope only time i've
seen that before was mike tyson when he
did his right undisputed truth
excellent i would love to catch a show i
did right on man i can send uh
i i can send you a link to this last one
i put it out on my own dude and it
worked real
really well for me man i don't know if
you ever saw where i duct taped myself
to the billboard to promote it
but uh that's another that's another one
i got away with the cops let me go yeah
they're taking selfies while you're up
there
yeah so uh so so we we talked about
power
and and that's uh stars you're
just a few episodes into filming power
book two
but uh it's not out yet season two um
no it's not out yet we're filming right
now um
but um i um well
the whole cast we had to film during the
pandemic because we owed uh two episodes
uh-huh and um it's weird because
the whole time we filmed no breakouts
no cases i think maybe one and that was
at a table read when
this thing first hit and nobody knew how
to
you know what i mean and we have all
that table read and whatever whatever
but since then i mean i take my hat off
to the people
at um the studio that we film at i'm not
at liberty to say where but
at the studio we film at take my hat off
to those guys because they've taken
every precaution possible
to keep the cast and not just the cast
but the crew right everyone who works
there
safe we haven't had any breakouts right
so
since we finished since we wrapped on
the first season
and since we started the second season
none
right wonderful yeah we've been we've
been getting away with it too filming
jackass
you know you know we're making a jackass
for
ah
is spike on board you bad i'm working
with spike today
nice give him my love man i would love
for him to do a video for me man
i did for sure man his vision is
his vision is crazy yeah it is
yeah we've been up to some stuff man and
i figured out what makes it different
being being so much older making a
jackass movie
it's like there's really not anything
different except your bones break a lot
easier
and it takes much less to knock knock us
unconscious
and we take longer to wake up
jesus i never want those words to come
out of my mouth lessons you've learned
i just mean that's how i'm going to
promote like when i got to promote the
movie
method man's like workout take care of
your body and steve's like yeah
you know yeah your bones break easier
maybe give your body a break
take a vegan diet for maybe like a month
or something like that and then you can
go back to yeah
something like that yeah a little
recovery period so so on on
ig your method man official i see you
got the the check mark on there i'm like
yeah and in real life official with the
check mark yeah
and then and and do you run that
yourself like when you're like oh i'm
gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna post this like
my that's my page okay cool man i run i
run everything on there um i also have
the
cal official page which is i don't run
that one though but it's for
you know the trees that we're
distributing in uh
l.a as we speak yeah dude let's get
started
we are expanding though so you might be
able to find it somewhere
to cal official and um to cal athletics
my um
fitness wear line yeah dude oh yeah i
love that [ __ ]
right on man did you ever expect like
when you were younger to see a world
where weed is becoming
legal everywhere like is that still
surprising
no um well yeah in a sense yeah but i i
knew it was coming one side
my first trip to amsterdam i was like
wonderful
that's great it had the same effect on
me as
california did like steve was telling
you earlier when um
i actually could purchase marijuana in a
store and walk out with it
you know yeah that's wild yeah you were
real happy i remember that
i mean i mean it's amazing because
what's even more amazing to me is that i
called it marijuana like four times
already
i don't even talk like that marijuana is
like a marijuana cigarette that's so
funny
yeah it's only right now because it's
being legalized that we have to use this
terminology it deserves respect
there you go yeah for sure i mean it
should have been legalized
20 years ago 50 years should have never
been criminalized i mean
40 years 40 years they've been fighting
and the plant is still winning that's
all i could say about that
right yeah yeah five's away i've been
sober for eight years and i'm
dying for you to light up that tree
right now
no way you're not getting me to blow my
hype on
recreational purposes i am working sir
that's a good point yeah oh dude i asked
that question man
paul said something real interesting
about about the
the well so i read that wu tang's record
deal is that what you're talking about
steve yeah wu tang's record deal was
like wu tang was signed but like method
man
if you want to make a method man record
you could go anywhere with it and my
question was
was that sort of just the record labels
oversight or did you have to fight for
that
no that was actually steve rifkin being
as innovative as his innovative
sweet smart ass is um steve
rivkin is responsible for the street
team that's that was his invention
you know so he's always been like an
innovator in in the game so
regardless of how people feel about
steve um rifkin he should be
in the upper echelon of hip-hop culture
um this guy gave
us that deal he he gave us the deal
where it was like rizza presented this
as a group
with the option to sign as solo artist
if loud couldn't
or did not feel like they wanted to
match the deal
that was being offered to one of the
artists then so be it the artist can
sign over
to another label we literally changed
the game
in a sense that when i signed the dev
jam dirty to elektra
uh joseph geffen and so on and so forth
we had labels that usually wouldn't even
speak to each other
actually working together for our cause
amazing that's great yeah dude that's so
sorry it was like a first
look deal like like the wu-tang label
they
they got the first opportunity to make
an offer
but if you pass it up then yeah so by
the time dirty was gone i was gone
jizzle was gone and the success of those
albums
trust me they weren't letting rayquan go
[Laughter]
and what came out of that is a classic
album only built for cuban links which
was followed by another classic only
built for cuban links too i mean chef is
what can i say about my brothers as a
whole but chef in my opinion
when he did those those two albums he
left earth
he left earth like completely like he
was he was in god dimension
like he was just every song
on on on and and chef still has the
capacity to do that when chef wants to
do that but chef is being a king right
now he's very regal
all right nice that's cool yeah dude and
what about uh i'm dying to ask you about
working with biggie smalls like when he
asks you to be on the what
did you have expectations of like where
his career was gonna go from there
no none of us did at that point you know
i think biggie was a bit more locked in
on where he wanted his career to go but
as far as me i
i was just rhyming i was doing what i
loved to do and just you know i wasn't
even
biding my time it was just that if it
goes it goes if it doesn't it doesn't
what
i mean i'll have something else to fall
back on but
being in the studio
with big i mean who wouldn't feel that
that aura of you know this this could be
something great
when you're there and you're doing the
work and the work is done and you're
listening to the song and
you know and you know who puffy is and
and the drive that he had and his
business savvy and
you see all this stuff coming to
fruition and to be a part of that is
like
it doesn't it doesn't hit you
until later on so you see it in
hindsight and you and you say to
yourself like man
i've done some things with some people
and i'm proud of the work
and that's and that's great right there
and i give a lot of love to tracy wapos
for um maneuvering and making that
happen because i wasn't even supposed to
do that record
oh what do you mean at that point in
time mutang like i said we had
all these labels working together for
our cause so
as far as doing records with other
people that's taking money
away from the clan and going over here
we didn't look at it so much as
all right we're going to go over here
and take their fans and bring their fans
back because at that point in time like
i said we're all starting out
so everybody's fans are everybody's fans
everybody's
uh status is about the same so
you you don't really benefit from
working with other artists if you're
still trying to build your [ __ ] up to
superstar status
and um when big in them approached you
know rizzo was more or less like we're
batting down the hatches we're not
giving anybody this work
unless i produce it
but so tracy waifus came and got me and
i went and did the biggie song and i'm
glad i did it i had to do the same thing
with the red man song for um
how high so you know me sneaking off
doing my thing kind of helped it worked
yeah and that you're the only feature on
that whole ready to die album
yeah yeah yeah it's pretty pretty epic
here
and in hindsight you look at that and
and you say yeah i was the only feature
and then you think well well we started
at
maybe he couldn't get in the other
future
nah but i doubt that and like i said
honor very honored that you know
even um that we had a camaraderie
that um uh you know that we stood the
test of time and even through
the uh dilemma that was going on between
himself and
a few clan members at the time and stuff
you know we still held a
a good friendship yeah dude so i i hear
you
you're talking about a lot of acting and
stuff what's going on with the music
right now you're making music
i do music because i want to now not
because i have to [ __ ] yeah yeah
nice man uh during the doing the
quarantining and pandemic and
all of that mess i i i i had a lot of
time to write
and study so um i may have some things
coming through the pipeline
uh myself and um havoc for my beat we
have an album that we
uh just uh finished um dirty p
coming soon and people are tired of
hearing about that because i've been
talking about it for months now but it
is done
and we're about to drop it all right i
have a
meth lab three um that should be coming
soon but it needs some work we gotta we
gotta really work on that one
and myself and rockwell are doing a lot
of remakes of old-school
so-called b side hits that i fell in
love with from
mc light queen latifah krs-1
uh ultra magnetic mcs just
you you'll have to absorb it when it
comes out and it's going to be good [ __ ]
definitely hell yeah dude and the best
way for people to find out
when these things are dropping what like
how they
i don't know black twitter they they on
everything okay
stay plugged in that's like funny they
plugged in yeah yeah yeah cause
i mean sometimes fans inform me of stuff
that i forgot i did so
yeah right all right but i'm just saying
like
if i are we sending people to follow
your instagram
you're like is there anything they want
to they can't if they want to i don't
stress things like that
my my um i use my social media for
business purposes mostly
and um some sometimes instant
gratification
yeah yeah like validation
yeah yeah but at the end of the day uh
it's nothing that i really
look at i can't even tell you how many
followers i have right now yeah
you know but if they want to stop
through for any kind of inspiration
motivation there's plenty of that on
there
as well as products to spy oh yeah you
know authentic products for them to buy
let me ask you this man after
after the last time i saw you so since i
saw you last
like were you aware when i was out of my
mind on drugs
trying to make a [ __ ] rap album
did you know that was going on i had no
idea and
if i did i would have probably cursed
you out for not calling me
because i'm you know i'm the alpha and
omega you know
the beginning and ending of this [ __ ] so
you might as well holler at me if you
haven't thinking
i'm just thinking
i am thinking because it was such an uh
an awful experience because i was just
so out of my mind on drugs and
you know it got so bad but
having had that experience and now all
these years later
i am like i do have a little itch to
like try to like have a redemption man
to get it right you know to make one
track that for whatever reason was worth
recording
so this isn't one of those joaquin
phoenix things right
no it was it was at the time
it was at the time but now he wants to
make it right now i just want to do one
track that
that wasn't a waste of time i don't want
to be kind of want to become
like a dude it was it was awful man it
was bad
and you know i saw i saw uh
or i heard about there was like an
interview or something and i think it
was you
where uh it came up how like how johnny
knoxville
and the jackass guys like came together
to like step in and do an intervention
on me
which ultimately saved my life man you
know like i've been cleaning clean and
sober ever since
and uh there was something it was a
really like like a touching
like you know really made me like
emotional to hear
i think it was you saying man if only we
could have done that for odb
you know like yeah and uh
it's just not always it's not always
that easy man it's uh
you know and i mean you you speak from
experience so
you know how hard that is
and then in a sense that
when dirty got locked up
isolated from the people he loved um
not a lot of members went to go visit
old dirty
i personally went there once with rizzo
to go visit dirty i didn't
like what i had saw um so dirty
coming home from that
you know a lot of love and caring from
his family his mom was there you know a
lot of support
um but i don't think it was enough to
keep dirty from being
old dirty yeah and
like someone i i can't speak to that
addiction
but i understand
but in the same breath i feel like
people that [ __ ] is so [ __ ] selfish
in a sense that especially people that
need you here
i'm pretty sure his family would rather
have him here especially his kids and
his grandkids they would rather
have him here clean and sober and boring
then you know back to the essence i do i
don't think
odb ever could have been boring man
there's no [ __ ] way that he could
have been boring dude
i agree i agree i agree it's such a it's
such a beautiful soul too because if you
knew anything about dirty dirty love
people
loved the [ __ ] out of people but he had
his vices you know
yeah uh yeah the world would be a better
place right now if he was still here
i'll tell you that much man
yeah dude how did you meet dirty um
through rizza thereza and it was just
this
this loud the thing about dirty that
stood out to me was
impeccably dressed all the time
and just loud and always had a 40 ounce
in his hand you know
and his cadence was always different he
never in my opinion
said his verses the same way
twice ever and he proved it on his
album because he did the same verse on
three different records
on that album the same verse i'll grab
the mic and i'll damage
you that verse he did it three times on
that album not the refurbished one
get the original copy because they took
it they took that song off of there
and added um a song off the jerky boy
soundtrack called dirty dancing
but he did it three times the same
verse as there is a vouch for me for
this and said it different
all three times to the point where
people didn't even notice it you
probably wouldn't have noticed if i
didn't tell you
yeah it's definitely still on there
twice
wow nice yeah yeah dude oh man i
i i gotta tell you matthew i'm so
grateful for
being able to do this man and i feel
like
everybody better [ __ ]
watch concrete cowboy as a thank you to
you today i think this episode's gonna
get a lot
a lot of uh attention for us man this is
like
we've had some some big names on here
but did this one personally getting
getting to talk to you on here man this
is a big honor man i really
steve you know that because we're
friends bro yeah i did
you've always been so good to me man and
uh
you know what i would like to say too
that if if there's a way for me to
extend
to rayquan just some good vibes man
you know like i feel like that that that
incident
all those years ago i know that he
really
really was upset and uh i never wanted
that man
and if there was just a way that i could
just put it out to him man like
then to clutch not to cut you off but
i'm sure chef sees the growth and he's
very approachable
and um yeah i can make that happen for
you guys man
that would be that would be super cool
man well it's been forgiven
all right did that mean kerry probably
laughing about this she probably gonna
laugh about this [ __ ] when she sing
it like crazy white boy pull the dick
out
she won't say dick though i'm sorry for
me mama cherry my bad
she won't use that word but right yeah
well mandy that means the world to me
dude it really honestly does
and and i'll see spike today and i'm
going to tell him
that uh that you said want him to do our
first video
you and havoc all right
i'm going to handle it i'm going to tell
spike and uh
yeah dude man it's it's a real honor
dude so let's let you get back to your
day man thank you for this
and uh everybody get that stars app
and catch up on first season of power
and even if you don't have the money
get it anyway yeah get your money right
right that's not what's happened
and and get ready for concrete jungle on
netflix yeah
boys concrete concrete cowboys man dad
you're you're a legend brother thank you
thank you thank you guys appreciate you
and steve keep fighting the good fight
i'm rooting for you brother oh dude
thanks so much dude was that
awesome or what yeah
it was it was completely awesome and
what else can i say man we got
sunglasses
at stevo.com a lot of people are asking
for them
when are you going to get sunglasses in
the pandemics screwed us
but the sunglasses are in
and so are the mugs and the shot glasses
and the hot sauce it's an exciting time
to go to stevo.com
but hey not to worry let's just reflect
on how [ __ ] awesome method man was
yeah dude